[Music]
foreign
I may be the only person who's ever
written an entire book
just to propose to the person they love
I said this before but you ruined it for
all men and that was brought my
attention the most romantic man on the
planet how long did you know that you
were going to propose almost two years
as soon as I got a book deal I knew that
this was how it was going to end in the
last chapter there's a line that says
when you choose to spend your life with
someone you're also choosing the person
who will tell your story when you're
gone and if you're lucky you will find
someone who only sees the best in you I
wrote that that's how I knew I was going
to get into the proposal and then I went
back and I started sort of the beginning
of my story and worked my way up to that
but I needed to know how it was going to
end and I knew that that was going to be
the ending your whole life or at least
the life that I knew you were always
like I am not getting married so now I
need details on the wedding
we have not had one conversation station
yet so excited Catherine doesn't even
have a ring yet right because we
couldn't do any of that stuff because
nobody knew right but I'll tell you this
okay from the guy who was like you know
this ain't never gonna happen there's
never gonna be a wedding
get ready for groomzilla
the other ending was good too
what does it feel like to have your baby
born the book it feels great you go
through all these emotions when you're
writing an insecurity and everything but
you have to get to the point and I got
to this a little while ago which is none
of that stuff bothers me anymore and
there would not have been a way where I
could have released it if I was still
bothered by any of those things that
I've been bothered with for so many
years of my life